hanging over the a para Mac River in
southern Peru is one of the great
engineering feats of the ancient world
the Incan Road system was one of the
great road systems of antiquity second
maybe only to the Roman road system it
covered 25,000 miles was in use for over
400 years and ran from Quito Ecuador
down to Santiago Chile but to have a
truly great road system you need great
bridges and the Incans had a particular
way of building bridges they didn't
build them out of metal or make them out
of stone they wove them from grass
there's only one remaining Incan bridge
today it's called the Quechua Chaka 300
years before Europe mastered the
suspension bridge the Inka were building
bridges that were a hundred and fifty
feet long when the Spanish first arrived
in South America they called them the
devil's work and were so scared to cross
them that they would crawl on their
belly the entire way it doesn't look
like the sturdiest thing in fact the
bridges are incredibly strong and MIT
professor had his students create one of
these bridges out of twine and found
that they could hold over 4,000 pounds
of tension or roughly about 56 people
spaced evenly across a 60-foot span
there used to be hundreds of these
bridges as part of the Incan road system
each bridge was overseen by a bridge
master among other things that the
bridge master was responsible for
maintaining the bridge collecting tolls
and for helping people across when they
had livestock or they needed some
assistance today the last Incan bridge
the cash flow chakra is overseen by the
last bridge master no Konkani guru ah
Giacomo a guy named Victoriano I was
lucky enough in 2010 to meet Victoria
and he showed me how he goes about
making a bridge now this process is
incredibly time-consuming
they take this grass that grows
abundantly all around and they wet it
with a little water and they rub it
together in their hands and then they
sort of slowly twist it into twine
weaving those together into larger ropes
which you can imagine how much time and
effort it would take to basically weave
what essentially is like hay into a
cable that's you know this wide around
once a bridge has reached the end of its
useful life it will be either cut down
and thrown into the river below or with
a little more pomp and circumstance
it'll be set on fire and then a
celebration is held and it's also the
chance to weave a new bridge and each
household is in fact responsible for 90
feet of woven rope kind of an amazing
idea right like instead of sort of
making one monumental structure that's
there forever and we kind of wait to
fall down one day they are in this
constant process of renewal even though
it's been there for five hundred years
it's actually been 500 different bridges
over that time and it is this cyclical
recreation this reaffirming of that
culture that makes it a real living
breathing piece of history so well a new
metal bridge has been installed just up
the river from the quechua chaka it's
still rewoven every year and it remains
a tiny little piece of the Incan road
system that's in perfect working order
to subscribe click here and to see more
videos click here the things that's so
interesting about it and can Empire they
almost took this alternate technological
path didn't have iron they didn't have
the wheel relay no no arch but what they
did have was fiber they had an
incredible mastery of vibrant they built
boats out of fiber
they built armor out of fiber which was
as strong pound-for-pound as the steel
that conquistadors wore and they even
had an incredibly complex language out
of fiber Creepo
they kept
taxes in this knotted set of fibers they
kept a demographic data or census data
how many people lived in what town how
old they were they kept all kinds of
financial records it was this really
masterful system you know you can almost
imagine a path where they continued to
long this line and they just continued
to invent and refine uses of fiber maybe
perhaps there are things that would have
been invented that we cannot even
imagine that we're all based in this
kind of fibrous technological focus